rémy talent il est fondateur de marianne
conseil et chroniqueur bonjour merci
d'être avec nous sur arte france alors
pour quelles raisons certains s'opposent
à ce texte pour certaines des maisons
est mentionné dans leur votre sujet il y
en a d'autres
je pense à deux en particulier la
possibilité de ce texte introduit pour
toute femme jusqu'au test jusqu'au terme
de sa grossesse de procéder à une
interruption médicale de grossesse au
simple motif d'une tresse psychosocial
il faut que chacun se rend bien compte
de ce que cela signifie
ça signifie qu'on va au delà nazis et
des enfants très concrètement 6 à 8 mois
9 mois
une femme vient il se déclare en
situation de détresse psychosociale
deuxième exemple il ya création
d'individus chimères c'est-à-dire de
d'hybride
en fait entre l'être humain et l'animal
dont la ministre frédéric vidal a été
incapable de garantir que ces individus
chimères ne seraient pas dotés d'une
conscience humaine
imaginez un petit peu le monde dans
lequel on est que lui je crois que c'est
quelque chose d'effroyable que cette loi
sans doute qu'on avait jamais eu de loi
comportant de tels le changement
anthropologique lent depuis le début de
la vème république et il est temps que
chacun se mobilise pour demander son
retrait
c'est bien le retrait total et vous
demandez aujourd'hui
oui parce que c'est si vous voulez ce
que je vous décris est à l'image du
reste du texte
c'est à dire qu'on considère qu'au nom
progrès toutes mes limites doivent
tomber et je m'étonne de cette attitude
du gouvernement qui est pris entre une
tension liberticide d'un côté on a vu
sur une question liée à la crise
sanitaire
et puis complètement libertaire de
l'autre ou de gérer de repousser toutes
les limites de lever toutes les tabous
et bien moi je le dis dans une société
saine
il est des transgressions qui ne doivent
pas être dépassées et c'est ce qui est
en train de faire le gouvernement
d'organiser une véritable différence
autour de ce projet de loi je pense que
il faut que chacun comprenne
vous avez des français sont des gens de
bon sens et s'il savait ce que contient
des produits bois bioéthique la plupart
d'entre eux évidemment ils seraient
farouchement opposés mais le
gouvernement a organisé dans
l'indifférence la crise sanitaire aussi
la contrefaçon de diversion et de kyoto
se ressaisir beaucoup il faudrait des
débats supplémentaires notamment avec la
société civile
bien sûr quand on a un texte qui
introduit de tels changements dans le
droit français qui va permettre aussi à
des enfants d'être élevée 100 perd
quelque chose qu'on aura organisé ou de
pouvoir mettre fin à la vie de deux bd
puisqu'il s'agit bien le bébé à six sept
huit mois ou de créer des embryons
chimère il aurait fallu un débat
national sur ces questions mais bien sûr
le gouvernement sait que s'il ya un
débat national
l'opinion publique s'exprimera très
largement contre ces évolutions
c'est la raison pour laquelle il a voulu
faire passer ce texte en continu
jusqu'au neuvième mois pour détresse
psychosocial c'est l'un des amendements
cette page j'imagine que ce ne sera pas
la femme ensemble de s'auto d'éclairer
en détresse psychosociale je voudrais
revenir avec vous sur la mobilisation on
l'a vu un peu partout en france contre
cette loi bioéthique mais c'est une
mobilisation qui est quand même le monde
attend d'atteindre celle qu'on avait
connue pour l'adoption du mariage
homosexuel
comment l'expliquez vous cela peut
paraître paradoxal que parce que
pourtant les enjeux sont bien plus
graves
en réalité je me permet quand même de
dire il ya eu un certain nombre de
manifestations d'enrobé des villes de
province je pense par exemple à bordeaux
à nantes saint brieuc à toulouse où
j'étais hier aux côtés des manifestants
je pense que la situation sanitaire et
par punis si vous voulez un petit peu
les cortèges
et puis peut-être dissuadent aussi
quelques manifestants ont participé
il n'empêche la gravité du texte reste
et demeure quel que soit le nombre de
personnes qui participent à ces assez
marche et je crois impose de pouvoir
mobiliser notre courage si on ne fait
pas contre le projet de loi bioéthique
on va en ce moment là d'arrêter toutes
formes de combat politique parce que
plus rien ne sera jamais capable de
motiver suffisamment pour aller dire
notre désaccord dans les rues de france
la mitaine et merci d'avoir répondu à
nos questions je rappelle que vous êtes
fondateur de marianne conseil et
chroniqueur marc siècle